[Musik]
am 15 mai 2006 wurde charlotte böhringer
in ihrer penthouse-wohnung über ihren
parkhaus in münchen auf unfassbar
brutale art und weise ermordet mit 24
hammerschlägen
[Musik]
später kam dann im laufe der zeit dass
der neffe verdächtigt wurde
[Musik]
schon wenige tage später war benedikt
otte neffe der charlotte böhringer der
hauptverdächtige
da hat ein motiv das erstklassige gar
nicht sein könnte die tatsache dass da
ein millionenerbe auf ihn warten würde
wir reden wir hier nicht von
kleinigkeiten
und alle seine probleme und sorgen wenn
mit einem male mit den tod der tante weg
gewesen
er wurde verurteilt zu lebenslanger haft
wegen besonderer schwere der schuld muss
er bis 2028 ins gefängnis doch verwandte
und freunde glauben weiterhin an seine
unschuld
der heimschule abdruck der wahl
letztendlich entscheidend dass er die
besondere schwere der schuld
zugesprochen bekam
es ist von anfang an nur einseitig
ermittelt worden nur gegen benedikt hat
[Musik]
ich habe keine zweifel das ist ganz in
topform
benedikt ist ja bis heute ganz fest und
seiner überzeugung zu sagen ich war's
nicht und dann sitzt da vielleicht eine
unschuldig im knast und einer der sie so
brutal ermordet hat läuft vielleicht
drei wohnen
ich bin ein rechtskräftig verurteilter
mörder
so formal korrekt weil die alte
auffassung waren dass irgendeiner und am
besten ich eingesperrt werden soll für
den mord an meiner tante
[Musik]
flash
ende
nein
erleben
michelle
zurück
[Musik]
mein name ist laura gehrmann ich arbeite
seit mehr als zehn jahren für bild und
hab natürlich viel mit mord prozessen
und auch anderen fällen vor gericht zu
tun die immer wahnsinnig spannend sind
und einer dieser fälle ist der fall von
charlotte böhringer
den ersten artikel den ich geschrieben
habe habe ich für online geschrieben und
habe mich erst mal angefangen zu belesen
ich kannte den fall ne ich habe
natürlich geschaut was haben wir schon
berichtet was am andere berichtet warum
gibt es solche zweifel
der fall hat natürlich aktuell nach der
tat für wahnsinnig viele gute
geschichten gesorgt erstmals ist das
opfer wach bekannt dann soll es auch
noch der liebling snapple gewesen sein
den fein macht so besonders das sehr
schnell entschuldige gefunden wurde
benedikt auch genannt ben zitiert
der fall lässt mich nicht los weil es
mir eigentlich nicht vorstellen kann
dass man in deutschland wir haben super
gutes rechtssystem unschuldig jemand im
knast sitzt und dann auch noch
lebenslang und danach wegen solch einer
schlimmen tat und der benedikt ist er
bis heute ganz fest in seiner
überzeugung sagen ich war's nicht
die kernfrage ist die groß muss der
zweifel an der schuld des angeklagten
sein dass man sich dafür entscheidet ihn
lebenslang hinter gittern zu stecken
oder halt freizusprechen
und um dem auf den grund zu gehen und
ein gefühl für den fall und auch die
beteiligten damals zu bekommen muss ich
nach münchen dort wo charlotte böhringer
vor 15 jahren ermordet wurde
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt einen termin bei peter
witting das ist der verteidiger von
benedikt ort der seit 38 jahren als
strafverteidiger arbeitet könnte
eigentlich schon längst in rente gehen
und irgendwie seinen ruhestand genießen
aber er sagt selber eigentlich der fall
dort lässt ihn nicht los
[Musik]
die tat soll am 15 mai 2006 begangen
worden seien in der zeit um 1800 1900 19
und 30
bands rockten soll es in der parkgarage
und angekommen sein er muss nach
auffassung der ermittlungsbehörden
handschuhe getragen haben er muss also
präpariert gewesen sein für einen
anschlag gleichsam gegen seine tante er
war bewaffnet mit einem unbekannten
gegenstand
er soll dann vor der eingangstür der
wohnung
charlotte böhringer gewartet haben wohl
wissen dass sie gegen 19 uhr 30
üblicherweise an einem montag zu einem
runter
zum stammtisch im tal geht und charlotte
böhringer war im begriff die wohnung zu
verlassen so die these und benedikt hat
hat dann 24 mal auf seine tante
angeschlagen bis sie am ende eines
kleinen fluss also vom eingang richtung
wohnungs inneres zu liegen kommt und
dort verstärkt
ich war das war immer
meine überzeugung so weit waren als
verteidiger überzeugt sein kann und darf
dass er nicht der täter ist
[Musik]
aktuell ist der stand der dinge so dass
der neffe von der charlotte bürgernah
der benedikt seit 15 jahren in der jva
straubing sitzt bis heute sagt ich habe
meine tante nicht ermordet ich schreibe
mich jetzt hier in der münchner
redaktion mit dem axel petermann
mittlerweile bekannt als bestseller
autor und als profiler der in sämtlichen
fällen als experte zu rate gezogen wird
aber bevor er natürlich als experte
fungiert hat hat er als wichtiger
kommissar gearbeitet und war an fällen
kann hat die gelöst und war nachher auch
stellvertreter leiter der mordkommission
in bremen das ist ja seit sieben jahren
eigentlich im ruhestand aber stadt nicht
zu machen oder seine freizeit zu
genießen beschäftigt er sich für
privatleute mit deren fehlen da hat sich
die familie hat also die eltern von den
benedikt hat und sein bruder an ihn
gewandt und haben darum gebeten dass er
sich doch noch mal die akteure von
damals anguckt und auf den tatort und
dann noch mal eine spur zu gehen und wie
wichtig und besonders ist das jetzt dass
sie diesen tatort auch noch mal beginnen
also dass pendler es über den tag ich
bin der auffassung dass mir die spuren
der tat gestern viel über den ablauf des
verbrechens berichten
also der täter stand hier schon das ist
die annahme das gericht für nach dem
stoff und hören immer die tür aufgemacht
hatte um heraus zu gehen ging das
gericht davon aus dass benedikt hat als
linkshänder mit links die tür aufhielt
und mit rechts auf sein späteres opfer
eingeschlagen hat also hier sollen die
ersten schläge gefallen sein und dann
hat sich eine dynamik entwickelt das
charlottenburger vor ihm zurück bis und
letztendlich hat sie dort hinten im
bereich noch weitere schläge erhalten
zunächst entstehen wie man auf den
spuren sehen kann und dann ist sie zu
boden gestürzt und das dann weiter auf
ihn eingeschlagen worden
dann ist ja nach oben gerannt so das
gericht hat es büro durchsucht hat dem
testament nachgelesen ob er weiterhin
bedacht ist dann soll er geld
eingesteckt haben und wieder geflüchtet
sein und für all das soll ja so zwischen
fünf und sieben minuten gebraucht haben
wenn man hier durch diese räume bzw
festsäle geht von diesem penthouse den
marmorboden anguckt die alten möbel
sieht kriegt man natürlich ein bisschen
dafür ein gefühl wie dieter böhringer
gelebt haben muss bevor sie dann
ermordet wurde das mulmiges gefühl weil
man natürlich nicht weiß was sie in den
letzten stunden vor ihrem vor der
ermordung passiert ist aber natürlich
auch ganz aufregend dass man überhaupt
die möglichkeit hat sich so etwas noch
mal anzugucken die charlotte hat hier
komplett alleine gelebt
und selbst wenn hier mehr möbel drin
waren und ein bisschen mehr leben es ist
natürlich schon ein riesiges zu hause
was natürlich sich alleine
wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen
bedrückung anfühlt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
herr petermann hier sind fotos und
gehört oder der spuren dann sind sie
auch noch mal genauer diese handschuhe
spur nachgegangen der vermeintlichen die
er dazu geführt hat dass eine besondere
schwere der schuld festgestellt werden
also ich bin zunächst das war davon
ausgegangen dass der gutachter recht
hatte mit seiner angabe dass der täter
handschuhe getragen hatte und es fängt
damit an dass gesagt wurde an der
eingangstür das kann man hier auf diesem
foto sind schon sehen dass die
eingangstür hier oben ist der spion habe
sich der abdruck eines handschuhs
befunden und dieser abdruck ist dann
gesichert worden und das ist jetzt hier
das bild es vom vermeintlichen
handschuhe abdruck wenn man sich das
sehr genau anschaut dann wird man sehen
das ist doch recht unregelmäßige
konturen sind manche so groß manche sind
klein manche sind lang gezogen das war
so der erste zweifel denen ich hatte
dass ich dachte wenn ich das so
unregelmäßig muss dass überhaupt ein
hemmschuh sein und dann wurde eine
zweite spur für die eine fernschuss
gehalten und dann habe ich mir die dann
angeguckt und vergrößert das hat mich
nicht überzeugt und deswegen habe ich
mir sachverständige gesuchte jedem halt
sich speziell mit solchen spuren
auseinandersetzen und die haben dann
gesagt das ist ein fingerabdruck besser
gesagt hier ist wahrscheinlich der
druckt eine an kannte wie wichtig ist es
dann festzustellen auf der cd schuhe
anhat oder so für das gericht war sehr
sehr wichtig es behauptete der täter sei
vorbereitet gewesen und diese handschuhe
abdruck der war letztendlich
entscheidend dass er die besondere
schwere der schuld zugesprochen bekam
[Musik]
einer der längsten indizienprozesse
münchens nach 93 verhandlungstagen dann
am 12 august 2008 das urteil benedikt
hat seine tante erschlagen dort
verwandte und freunde glauben weiterhin
an seine unschuld
mich fasziniert an dem fall dass der
benedikt es vielleicht einfach nicht
gewesen ist
deshalb treffe jetzt alexander stevens
hat damals für die staatsanwaltschaft
gearbeitet als der bands vor gericht war
[Musik]
es heute selber rechtsanwalt und wird
uns ein bisschen von seinen eindrücken
erzählen und auch so ein bisschen von
der seite der staatsanwaltschaft und
auch der richter
mit dem parkhaus mord kam ich in
berührung weil ich zur zeit der
verhandlung des parkes mannes bei der
staatsanwaltschaft meine wahl station
gemacht hatte natürlich kriegt man dann
auch das ein oder andere mit was man
vielleicht als außenstehender nicht
mitbekommen hätte und damit war das
interesse geweckt und jahre später habe
ich ein buch geschrieben bei dem es um
perfekte morde gehen und deswegen habe
ich mich also diesem diesem fall
angenommen da sehr sehr tief greifende
recherchiert urteil natürlich gelesen
auch akten gelesen und mir dann ein
eigenes bild gemacht und diese
geschichte zu papier gebracht sitzt der
benedikt hat ihrer meinung nach zu recht
hinter gittern also dass er zu recht
hinter gittern sitzt davon bin ich zu
100 prozent definitiv überzeugt wie
wurde der benedikt hat damals verhört
wie sind die ermittler daran gegangen zu
dem zeitpunkt hatte die münchner
mordkommission
nachweislich es sich fortgebildet in den
usa zu einer gewissen methode der
sogenannten geriet methode und die macht
also folgendes da gibt es nicht nur den
good cop und im bett kopf diese methode
kennt man ja der eine schreit und ist
dann für den
beschuldigten für den betroffenen dann
diese aggressive person vor der angst
hat und der andere so der nette der
kumpel zu dem man sich dann irgendwie
hingezogen fühlt und sich dann
gegebenenfalls öffne zur theorie bei der
methode ist es noch eine ganze ecke
krasser um das einfach mal ganz kurz
übers knie zu brechen
versucht man da den leuten letztlich die
parteien zu reden indem man sie mürbe
macht die werden über stunden lang
vernommen
und denen werden dann auch dinge in
aussicht gestellt die wenn sie die taten
einräumen niemals zu treffen werden
[Musik]
dann werden alternative vorgegeben damit
gesagt naja du warst doch da und da aber
du hast du doch eigentlich gar nichts
schlechtes gedacht also das messer in
die hand genommen hast du wolltest doch
damit eigentlich nur irgendwie schnitzen
oder sie geben ihm alternativen vor die
er dann aufnimmt und wenn er dann auf
eine wissen sie sie haben den täter und
dann gehen sie halt richtig hart mit dem
ins gefecht
[Musik]
dass man ihnen letztlich eingeständnis
dass es das eigentliche ziel der mit
methode dann aus der nase gezogen hätte
das gibt es ja eben nicht aber sah sich
wohl genötigt und ich finde das wort
genötigt passt auch ganz gut dinge zu
sagen und sich dadurch in eklatante
widersprüche zu verstricken
[Musik]
hingebracht wurde nachdem er verurteilt
wurde wir haben glücklicherweise die
erlaubnis bekommt ihn zu besuchen auch
drei stunden zeit und mit
sämtliche geschehnisse von damals und
sein leben heute zu besprechen wir
dürfen das gespräch aufnehmen aber
leider nicht viel
[Musik]
können sie sich danach daran erinnern
wie sie dann von der polizei befragt und
vernommen wurden und wie sich das blatt
gewendet hat dass sie sich nicht mehr
als zeuge geführt haben sondern wirklich
als verdächtigen
sind zwar blieben schlachthaus da es
sich angefasst habe habe ich gemerkt ist
es natürlich kalt stellen es ist von
anfang an nur gegen benedikt ort
ermittelt worden die uhrzeit war schon
beschlossene sache der tote mann ist
dieses gebäude
er hat ein motiv das erstklassige gar
nicht sein könnte viele der vom gericht
angeführt und indizien nicht schlüssig
sind und wie alles drum herum
konstruiert wurde zeitfenster ich war ja
vor ort da haben sie mich genauso aus
wie die tatsache dass da ein
millionenerbe auf ihn warten würde wir
reden jetzt ein kleines kalten ich kann
zwar eigentlich bis heute nicht
verstehen kann sagt der zeuge das und
montag etwas anderes nach 100
verhandlungstagen sind wir bei sie karin
irgendwie mit irgendwas haben dann mal
kurz gehörte nun fahren dann halt wieder
irgendwie und irgendwas und keiner hat
sie wie sie wieder unterwegs und zu
hause und haben die spuren nicht meine
schuld gehört dort nicht hin
[Musik]